foreign
[Music]
ER Jen Wilson and welcome to this film
independent presents q a for the
National Geographic documentary the
territory by Alex pritz special thanks
to our lead sponsor the hifa and our
virtual screenings partner Vision media
and now please welcome our guest today
director Alex pritz thank you so much
for joining us Alex Thanks Jen
um the first question is one that I
often start with right off at the top
which is you know we have a lot of
members of film independent that are
aspiring filmmakers so I wondered if if
you could speak a little bit about how
you became a filmmaker
oh that's a great way to start
um
I came into film kind of from the side I
studied science
um studied earth science and climate
science and was really interested in the
way that we relate to our planet the way
that we think about our planet
um and just found that film was the most
interesting way to explore some of those
ideas that I had thought would take me
in a you know more research driven
Direction but actually found that you
know film and the Arts were a better way
for me to explore some of these ideas
um
and yeah it just you know kind of one
thing in front of the other I I started
out as a cinematographer working on a
lot of other people's films
um shot on John casby's fantastic film
when lambswick and lions and then had
the opportunity to work on the first
wave
um last year and so it kind of learned
my way around sets and
um you know working in these different
environments and felt with the territory
like I was ready to embark on a feature
that I would direct and so this is the
first film I've made myself
so how did you uh end up making a film
about this um Brazilian indigenous
Community
wow wow is that how you pronounce it
yeah
[Music]
um
it's a it's a different kind of sound we
don't have as much in English but
um I I found this story through nadina
the activist at the center of the film
and I had read about her work uh seen
some interviews that she'd done online
and just thought you know holy okay I
don't know if I can swear in this but
you know holy cow this is like the most
incredible woman I've ever seen
um she's she's out here defending the
rainforest defending indigenous rights
and doing it in a part of the world
where uh in the 2018 elections in Brazil
80 percent of people voted um for the
far right candidate Shire bolsonaro so I
just reached out to her and said look I
I love what you're doing I think you're
an incredible force and if bolsonaro
this was during the campaign that I
reached out I said you know if if he
wins it looks like your life and your
work is going to become so much more
difficult I'd like to be there um with
you through that and could I come meet
you And So It Started from these really
humble beginnings
um you know just a one-way ticket to to
meet her in Brazil and quickly saw that
that this was a real story with with
very real Stakes
um and it grew to then incorporate the
indigenous perspective of the Euro wild
people who nadina had this 40-year
relationship with
um and you know obviously that has
become the central focus of the film in
many ways but it started through through
nadina herself
so the Amazon rainforest is um the
importance of this film you know is that
we are we all know very well now that
the Amazon rainforest has been called
the lungs of the world and you know the
impact of its damage what it has for the
rest of us and for climate change
and so were you thinking about that when
you were filming the scenes of like the
the trees being chainsawed and and
things being burnt because I felt
physically in pain watching that
it fills
so serious now in the past I've seen so
many environmental documentaries and it
feels so much different now
um were you thinking about that in the
way that you were filming what was going
on
yeah absolutely I mean I think we we're
all aware at this point that that the
Amazon rainforest is one of the biggest
and strongest buffers we have against
runaway climate change and if we want to
have a habitable planet you know there's
there's no Planet B this is this is what
we've got and if we want to make it work
if we want to continue to survive on
this Little Rock in space we've got to
keep that Forest standing it's it's
really simple and so filming with these
farmers and and settlers that are
invading this protected indigenous land
and burning it away in the hopes that
they can get you know just a small piece
of land for them and their family uh it
felt so short-sighted and myopic and and
painful to to be there witnessing that
but at the same time it felt really
important to be able to get those images
because as we were filming them
bolsonaro was in the media saying it's
ngos and Indigenous people lighting Fire
to the Rain Forest to drum up support
for their you know campaign to undermine
Brazil is National sovereignty classic
far right thing and so getting those
images and showing what's really
happening felt felt really important and
a lot of the motivation to do that came
from early conversations with betate and
nadina who said if you want to do
something different if you want to make
a film that really resonates go talk to
the people that are burning and lighting
fire to the rainforest like they're the
cause of this conflict not us you can't
just talk to us and understand why this
is happening we're the recipients of
this conflict and they're out there
doing this with impunity without much
fear of repercussion
and and they'll talk to you you know it
might be hard at first but eventually
you can you can get in there and they'll
be open with you because they really do
see themselves as Heroes they think of
themselves as The Virtuous Pioneers
going out and creating something out of
nothing uh and I as an American felt
that there was a really strong parallel
there to my own country's history and
the founding National mythology of
America this idea of manifest destiny
the idea of divine right to the land the
idea that land is empty you know devoid
of life until some western or white
person comes along and discovers it
charts it along their you know X Y
coordinates obviously all of that is
false but I saw it playing out in real
time in Brazil and thought you know this
is actually really important to
critically investigate
so when you when you interviewed the
farmers and and the settlers what what
was their attitude towards you
uh so we'll just start with that what
was their attitude towards you
they were really skeptical at first um
you know we had this conversation with
pizza and Nina and and they said why
don't you go and and try to film with
these guys try to make contact and I was
like genuinely a little scared at first
you know these are unpredictable people
I didn't know anything about them
um they're very closed off very
skeptical and when I first met with them
they were very skeptical of me they
thought that
um you know I was there to do a hit job
on them and
they really see themselves though as as
Heroes like I said that they are the
people on who's back the country has
been built and that they should be
celebrated for for doing that at one
point Martin's one of the settlers says
you know this is how Brazil was built in
every other country too and in a sense
he's correct that is how Brazil was
built through chainsaws and through the
expropriation of indigenous land and
violence towards those people and it is
how America was built and a lot of other
you know settler settler Colonial
countries that doesn't make it right but
it is true and so I I basically said
look I'm here I will give you guys an
honest platform to try to speak your
truth and I will try to understand where
you're coming from and what your
motivations are and I'm not going to
paint you as a storybook villain you
know as a one-dimensional creature a
Mindless you know uh creature of evil
and and that ended up working out you
know I think as well spending equal time
filming them in the hot sun digging
holes as filming them you know stealing
land
showed them that that I was going to try
to to capture the complexity of the
situation that they find themselves in
and I really do genuinely feel
compassion for a lot of these people who
are poor and marginalized Farmers you
know the thing that they're not seeing
that I see
is that they're a victim of the same
forces that are plundering indigenous
land it's to the benefit of the
political and business Elite Class in
Brazil as in many other countries to
keep poor marginalized people fighting
amongst themselves when really the enemy
to Sergio and Martens and these these
settlers are not indigenous people that
are holding them back it's these Mega
farmers and ranchers creating
monoculture beef and soy plantations
that they can't compete with and pushing
them into the economic periphery where
they feel their best option is to go out
and colonize new land as the tip of the
spear you know eventually feeding these
same systems that put them in that place
in the first place
right and and it's easier to try to push
push the indigenous people around
because they're not wealthy and don't
have the defense
so one of the one of the things
that um the Trap do you call them a
tribe or you call them a community uh in
Brazil and Indigenous people is
preferred indigenous people
um one of the things the the indigenous
people
um
learn seem to learn to do for for
themselves is to use technology like
they use a drone to see how close the
settlers are getting and which parts of
their land they're on and then they
start using the cameras
um did they have this technology when
you met them or who was it that
introduced them to using things like
this
yeah so be today this young 18 year old
um really a kid when we first met him he
was a digital child you know he had a
cell phone he was on Instagram he he was
well connected to the world and that was
part of the reason that at such a you
know tender young age of 18 he was given
this huge responsibility of becoming the
leader of his people and defending this
huge area of land that's crucial for the
entire world's survival but also you
know the future of of his embattled
indigenous community and so
part of the reason for that was his
ability to harness the media and harness
you know these new forms of technology
so in the film you see drones you see
walkie-talkies GPS all of this is
equipment that betate got himself
through Grant applications working with
Medina to try to get these tools that
could help expand you know their
surveillance capabilities when covid
came we as a film team looked at the way
that betate had been using media already
and said wow you know here we are making
an artistic film these guys are using
film for evidentiary purposes maybe we
can combine this you know be today how
do you guys feel and the response we got
from the Uruguay was yes we can film the
final chapter of this story bring us
better audio equipment bring us you know
Real Cinema cameras and we've got it
from here and so from covet on we begin
working with the community as
co-producers of the film uh you know to
document their experience from the
inside out but yeah it's one of the most
interesting parts of the film I think is
is seeing this community go from being
kind of pushed around in in some ways
you know mounting a Fierce and and brave
resistance but then finding their voice
politically through the media and
through this idea of narrative
sovereignty of asserting themselves
um in a more public way led by Beach
detail this inspiring young individual
was was so cool and one of the things I
know maybe this is a long answer but I
don't know I love it keep going one of
the things bolsonaro and people on the
right do in Brazil is try to denigrate
people as you know they'll use it as a
slur iPhone Indians meaning that if you
have a cell phone if you engage with
technology you can no longer claim
access to that identity meaning
conversely that the only real indigenous
people in their Twisted minds are you
know deep in the forest not engaged in
political life not causing any trouble
for them and I just felt so inspired by
Beach attacking these young people this
new generation that reject that false
binary outright and say no I am
technologically sophisticated media
Savvy I'm here I'm causing trouble for
you and I'm in touch with my culture and
my Heritage and my roots and that those
those are not separate things actually
they're they're the same thing
um and you know one final thing is after
we've we've finished the film be today
uh has just become the first member of
the Euro wild to go to university he's
studying journalism now at the federal
University of hendonia this fall was his
first semester so really excited for him
as well so yeah I was I was going to ask
because uh
um so many things have happened now
because Brazil just elected a new
president
was this it in the last week right yeah
yeah and um I was going to ask you like
what what is going on with the
indigenous people now how are they doing
and do you think the regime change in
Brazil is is going to be positive for
them
yeah the the election that happened a
week ago
um Lula uh de Silva won against
bolsonaro and for the ottawao and and
all of the indigenous communities I've
spoken to in Brazil this is um you know
really welcome change uh I think it's at
the same time naive to think that their
problems will go away with a new
president these are problems that have
been around for hundreds of years
generations of people have been fighting
against these issues
and you know the the fight will
certainly not cease to exist but at
least there's somebody in power who will
listen now and and who's open to
thinking about this uh in a in a way
that expands Beyond Simple you know
short-sighted resource plunder do you
know if they're still having people
um trying to come on the land and
start Farms on the land are they still
having to deal with that
the the Uruguay was one of the most
threatened and invaded territories in in
all of Brazil and so there are tons of
illegal miners loggers Invaders
um you know flooding their land
uh and you know in some ways we're a
little worried that this fall before
Lula gets in maybe there's even a bigger
push because this might be their last
moment of some impunity
um but at the same time the the other
wow and a lot of other indigenous
communities are are using media in these
really exciting ways
are starting a media and Cultural Center
where they're going to have a Production
Studio in their land
um where they'll be continuing to make
films and advocate for themselves the
same is happening with tons of other
indigenous communities across Brazil and
it's part of this really exciting
movement of young people
um using the media and I think that also
played a role in in this election as
well um you know certainly the
indigenous movement was was strong and
loud and and played a part in this last
election
um
it's really
um
completely amazing to me
um
because I was you know in in the
beginning you know you see all the
the trees being chopped down and things
being burned and you're and and then you
know uh Nadine is trying to call for
help from the you know the government
in not getting in it basically not
getting
get any response or a response that's
like I can't do anything for you with an
attitude of like we don't really care
and you're just like what are they going
to do but then when you start to say
like the how the use of the technology
because she you know she tells them
they're saying they can't do anything
unless they have proof and then they're
like okay here we go we're gonna do it
I'm gonna give you some proof and I was
just I was amazed at how they embraced
that I thought it was also so
interesting that that shot of um
umitate is that what his name is yeah he
was going to give a speech and he was
like I think I'll start with me and this
is the elders in Medina was like no
you need to do the elders first trust me
it was just so interesting you know like
how young he is and and like his
perspective on things versus hers
because you know she's been there for a
longer time out of time
um
so that that was really interesting she
she carries a lot of wisdom and she
would do the same thing to us all the
time too like hey Alex no that's not how
you're gonna do this that doesn't fly
here
um and and she was teaching me the whole
time we were so lucky to have her both
as you know this strong powerful uh
protagonist in the film but also just as
a mother figure and mentor to our entire
team that was learning
um about a culture that wasn't ours
about a part of the world that
um you know we were we were absorbing a
lot of new information around him and
she
she has that that teacher Levi professor
at heart
and so in one of the more shocking parts
of the movie
um one of one of the indigenous peoples
actually killed is actually found
murdered
um and the police do come I'm just
wondering if anything ever came from
that police investigation if they have
figured out if it was one of the
settlers who did it did anything happen
with that
the police have arrested a suspect
um
and it's it's a long convoluted process
you know I think Justice is elusive in
this part of Brazil and it's required a
ton of effort from nadina from the Euro
wow to to get to this point the suspect
who's been arrested was already in jail
for life and so
um you know no major
disruption to anybody's life by having
them be the the suspect
uh at first it was treated as a hate
crime you know related to the
environmental Defense work that Ari was
engaged in now it's being sent back down
as uh you know the police are claiming
it's a simple bar room fight or
something of the sort and so that's all
being appealed by the uruba wow now and
um we will we will see how that process
goes but the the fight for justice is
certainly continuing
yeah that part was really amazing and
it's also amazing to see
how they all just like regroup and get
themselves back together and keep going
after you know like that's the Ultimate
Weapon of intimidation is we're we're
just gonna start killing you then if
you're not gonna let us do what we want
to do
yeah and it's amazing to me that they
recover from that and and just keep
going on although I suppose this is a
you know hundreds of years of enduring
something like this
and so in a way they're sadly used to it
yeah it was
incredibly
messed up unfair it was a really hard
thing and you know I think they
be today
um took on more responsibility after
that for sure but I don't think the
community has recovered I mean he was a
teacher in a local school he has two
kids that he's Left Behind he's got a
wife and a mother and
um was really very active in in the
territorial defense and so the the hole
that's been left by his passing is uh
his murder is is still a big part of the
community I think was that really
shocking for you and your crew when that
happened and then that did that sort of
make you you all feel
like they make you feel
good that you were making the film
because
what happened justifies you know you're
capturing this or or did you have a sort
of a feeling like I want to give up this
is too much it's too intense
no I think we definitely all we we
stopped filming for a while we
questioned whether it was worth it to
keep going you know what the the
physical risks to everybody involved
were what the you know emotional weight
of trying to continue this story without
him would be
um it was a
a long hard reflection I think through
that period of time
um especially you know the the urawao
culture doesn't speak about the dead
um you know it doesn't carry images of
the dead people are buried with all
their belongings and so
you know it was a really hard thing to
to talk about I also it was at the very
beginning of covet that it happened so
we weren't able to I wasn't able to
physically be there and grieve with the
community it was a really hard time
period I think
[Music]
so I'm just wondering
um
I was going to ask what what do you hope
that people's major takeaway from the
film is
um
I hope that people uh you know follow
these young indigenous storytellers as
they they keep making films and and
putting work out into the world I think
you know for me one of the clearest
things is that indigenous people are the
best Guardians of the forest you know
they are the best defense we have
against deforestation indigenous people
are less than five percent of the global
population and defend over 80 percent of
global biodiversity uh so if if we want
to keep living here
um we've we've got to have them be at
the center of every conversation about
climate change that's happening there
can't be conversations that exclude them
from here on out
um
yeah I think that would probably be the
main one for me
so what's next for you do you have
another film planned or already been
working on another film
uh the consummate question
um I yes I've got a lot of ideas I'm
really excited about
um I'm gonna see through the territory
you know this fall and we've got a
really strong impact campaign planned
around the rest of the film um you know
some legislative goals uh working to
support more indigenous filmmakers and
so that will be you know a continued
Focus over the next couple years but I'm
definitely excited to get back to uh
shooting and making another film soon
and when does the territory come out
we don't have an official release date
yet but it will be before the end of the
year on Disney Plus
great
well thank you so much for coming today
and uh talking with me
um I really appreciate it this film was
amazing it's amazing and eye-opening and
just an incredible watch I think that a
lot of people should see it thank you so
much Jen
[Music]
thank you
[Music]